[Music]
we should do that
we're just talking we should do a uh we
should do the
behind the patreon wall the what we say
before we roll
that would be every we would make a
hundred thousand we would make more
money
yeah and lose every friend i've ever had
um
it's juicy gossip guys it's you it's
pretty jesus
um bianca hi tell me about your week
kenny did you
realize that you're gonna have to do
this segment and prepare
i thought of one thing uh-huh it was
hella scary
are you ready yeah so i'm off
to an adventure i'm in an uber i have
this in the front seat for some reason
and my two friends are in the back and
we're at us
where we like pull off from a a light
and we're driving
and a guy
comes up to us in the middle of the
street so we're not at a light we're
just driving
and uh someone is turning left in front
of us so our lane slowed down
he's laying to the right of us open
he comes up pulls up right next to
the car so i'm in the passenger seat
this person's in their driver's seat
this is like i it's like there used to
be a thing called you make the call
on uh football games or baseball games
they would do like
a guy would slide in they'd show the
plane then go you make the call
what happened and they'd run a
commercial then come and go like he was
out or whatever now i'm trying to go
like did he take his dick out
did he spit did he say something racist
uh
or did he puke no i don't think he puked
okay
i don't now you just said i said done
but
can you get a little more extreme than
puking i don't think so
[Music]
um there's a better one of those well
there's a better
it's like that's the old one there's
like a stab one
um we like to do our production meetings
on the air uh more extreme
okay then taking his dick out dude it
was
so scary so he pulls up
to the passenger side he's like this i
have to show you
[Music]
both arms out with a long
lens dslr camera taking a photo of me
like not like he took both hands off the
steering wheel
and was like halfway out of the car is
the
is his car moving no stop okay pulls up
stops and comes up but as soon as he
pulled up kind of
i looked to the right both hands
on the camera long lens taking a photo
is this about the guardian article that
we were featured on i'm like i
stop it that sprite commercial was like
four years ago
uh this is a this is how uh
passionate the feelers are just joking
it was so scary why
do you know why no of course i don't
know why
i do you think it was like some jerk-off
[ __ ] or do you think he thought well i'm
sitting in like something famous
happened there's no way he could think
something famous happened i mean there
was an uber sticker on the back
look i'm as famous as anyone in the
country and i write ubers all the time
i mean you know when there's a famous
person they don't go
one lone ranger going to chase like they
there's hubs
i bet if there's a scandal they do yeah
but
it's me yeah well as i'm saying what do
i what don't i know
and neil i thought first of all i
thought it was a gun yeah
and it was night that's by the way
that's uh west hollywood
that's a west hollywood drive-by
like freeze [ __ ]
i don't have my glasses on um and then i
i got very
i just got very freaked out i was so
scared and then he peels out
what was that about don't know i mean
you did you fame's terrifying
part of me no i'm famous but but that's
this is nothing new
i know it doesn't but that's a tenth of
what
like you'd see the amy winehouse
documentary and it just is a [ __ ]
nightmare like oh this is a nightmare it
was
so scary and then i thought i was like
i'm being
pr like i'm being sex trafficked and we
made jokes out like oh
they probably want him a little younger
but
uh i don't know what that was
but it i know it was really unnerving
was he
middle eastern black no it was a camera
face
i had no idea but i'm telling you he
knew what he came face like what i have
when i'm on camera
work work the runway girl uh i just he
felt like he knew exactly why he was
doing it
part of me then i took an inventory of
the car the nice chinese gentleman
driving
i was like are you in an insurance scam
like are you do you have an
insurance claim out i asked my friends i
don't know why else someone would follow
it was so scary they he i don't
i mean why i can't even comment because
i don't understand it i
it just someone pulled up but why would
you be so
he kept taking photos and i put my bag
up to my face
and then he kept taking photos so in the
old days in new york when
at the puerto rican day parade dudes
would videotape hot women
and it was so pitiful like what do you
mean like
as they mentioned girls on the street
dudes would film them and it was like
dog like what are you gonna do with it
right like a jerk off in the winter
you'll be able to get porn in the winter
like you're not like but i want to
remember these times
in central park when hose was wearing
jeans
like okay um
the uh that's that's wild and i'm sorry
that that happened to you
no it was really weird it reminded me of
this very weird thing happened to me
near there at a goodwill where i'm
pretty sure i was almost
serial killed um
i was in a goodwill looking for some
costume
me and my friend who's a guy came
together and
i was like okay i gotta go this way i'm
gonna it'll i'll be a while and
everywhere i
was there was this one dude but he never
ever looked at me he never even looked
towards me
um but i just started noticing him for
some i don't know he just gave me the
creeps a little bit so i
i wanted to see if i was being a little
paranoid and i started going to really
very
very strange places that no one goes
through in goodwill
and he had neighborhoods of goodwill
like the blanket the hood the hoodwell
i just they went to the blankets like no
one's like [ __ ] blind
like the blankets of goodwill neil can
you believe that and it's one of my
favorite instagram accounts
keep keep then keep going good don't
lose the blankets
so into blankets where you'd be safe
because the last thing of
the only thing that could kill you in
goodwill is a [ __ ] blanket
unless you went over like i then i hid
in the knives
oh then he'll never get you now
anyways i went to the blanket i'm like
okay he's for sure not i'm playing dumb
the whole time
and i turned around and there was it's
next to the chair furniture and he's
he was just right there and i was so
terrified so i texted my friend i'm like
we gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
someone's following me and my friend i
roll emoji's like no one's following you
[ __ ] it's goodwill
um and i said can you actually come meet
me in the blankets and just be very
boisterous if like
pre just say hey babe there you are
something and he did that
and that guy got up and ran out like ran
but just briskly walked out
straight away great yeah
i like it i was a goner i'd be doing
this podcast by myself
getting all the money do you understand
me
i need your protection neil it does it
for free what did i do great question
it was a lot of zooms this week gang
these
bank commercials aren't gonna cast
themselves they're not gonna
storyboard themselves they're not gonna
locations got themselves they're not do
you do all that why are you doing all
that
so you have to you have to is there
someone that can do that
no i can't allow i mean i've heard like
louie would let people
pick locations for him no like and look
at photos but he wouldn't go on
i think if you get to a certain level
i don't think you do have to go to the
tech scout because you can't
i can't film something unless i know
what it looks like
unless i've been there i'm not just
gonna be like
i don't it's yeah no one's imagination
is that good i i also feel like a piece
of [ __ ] going like
and we'll figure it out we've got 80
people that need you to
figure it out now man i'm not ready
right um
so a lot of that and uh what's the least
favorite part about the
pre production location scouting that
seems like it'd be nice you get a
lunch well
that's a good point good point about
lunch
because i get my sweet green salad
uh every time i do a location scout
right but the crew got
medicinal farms now anyone who really
is a tuesday feeler of the highest level
knows that mendocino farms is one of my
top toppies
that's very good so i got a free salad
and a free sandwich
would you would you get the vegan balmy
yeah i knew it
no cilantro no cucumber thanks what's
the cilantro cilantro
yeah um so i'm a tuesday taster
um so uh so that's the worst part
because you guys
drives [ __ ] simi valley to go like
this is the mall you're offending all
the police officers
well i listened to the podcast i did say
um
that uh the i
used the black dp uh malik saeed who's
the
malik all of spike lee's movies and i've
like
been kind of a low-key hero man forever
or not hero but i [ __ ] with them
um and uh but so we're
in simi valley i go you know if you need
justice this is the place to get it
malik said some really cool [ __ ]
he was talking about how
degraded culture has gotten and he was
saying
he goes he's like probably 50 or
something
he like was a [ __ ] i don't think he
was lead cameraman and malcolm x like
[ __ ]
he's like a [ __ ] you know
and uh he's like man
when i grew up in la he's like there was
[ __ ] all-stars
everywhere and i was like what do you
mean he's like just [ __ ]
dudes doing backflips and with the
best-looking women
and like i just love people that see
culture that way
he didn't go to college he just bought a
camera and filmed [ __ ] and like
was he saying no he's like now it's just
like
everything's online everything's online
and there's no
you needed a lo you needed local
all-stars because you didn't have access
to international all-stars
so you needed like it's like people
could sing
people would like there was cool um
anyhow uh and i
i you know i like plant medicine i've
heard it i
sat with some plant medicine this week
and uh it was
pretty fantastic and
uh this is how much ayahuasca has
changed me
as a person driving home the other night
near here see a guy
crosswalk on ocean park boulevard
with near me and uh
and he was in a wheelchair and he's like
uphill
so i just parked and i was like hey man
you need help and uh he did
and i pushed him up the hill for like 10
minutes
well that's nice that is that is nice
we have we have songs that we have to go
over by the way yes um
and didn't once think about getting good
boy catholic points
did you give him some money no
he offered he was going to buy me
i was supposed to meet him at el pollo
loco on thursday what
is it you joking no you made a date with
him well he made a date with me i didn't
i wasn't like i wasn't like yes it's a
deal what did he say
hey well here's the great thing here's
the great thing about homeless people
is our uh home home without home
houseless
houseless sans accommodations
adobe uh he he i was pushing him in like
the bike lane
and at one point i'm like yeah let's go
to the sidewalk and he goes don't be a
[ __ ] idiot give me the bike later i'm
like okay
he's an idiot yeah he's just drunk and
mentally ill
um but didn't get didn't think about
good boy points only am saying it now
so that people understand what this
plant is all about
uh okay i mean it's a good
it's a good one neil but it's also like
i it i was surprised by how
not like grossed out not no
not i was just like if i can help the
guy wait focus how did
how what how did the date come about
because he
said he was getting fifty thousand
dollars the next day
he was that he was no he also said he
owned
really i mean he just said he just had a
bunch of things he was so what do you
say he said
i'm um i'll be the polio loco tomorrow
to
come by i'll buy you a taco okay i love
it
did you go no because i don't they don't
have any actually they might have
vegan options now they do they have a
maybe they have an
uh impossible they have a i think they
have a so
fritto so free that's that's um
chipotle and shout out to them for
having a bucket of
tofu they're the only they're it's
[ __ ]
very good really so freed us at chipotle
get them very good do you eat the tacos
at jack-in-the-boxes apparently you've
never been bacon
that's what i was thinking they have
beyond beyond yeah el pollo i don't know
what they have
but i tell you what i left eleven
dollars
worth of merch on the table by not
showing up
um we got a bunch of songs okay let's
play
[Music]
i love the dixie i love the clarinet
music
we you got to replace the vocals
shawn cantorwitz love your spirit can
you need to
just hire somebody or just or just like
oh
you either have the wrong voice or you
have the wrong pitch right now yeah
so spend money on a barbershop quartet
and really do it right
um
[Music]
that sounds like the beginning of a
kanye
song from the mix tape that when he was
releasing the friday the good music
friday mixtapes
there's a song with most def and
ronnie eisley and ronnie
um and uh swiss beats
that's the big that's sounds like the
beginning of that i like it a lot it's
also it's
it's a sample did you
watch the earthwood fire versus that i
didn't we'll get to that
i've seen the outfits there's so
yeah that's a good one because the kid
says man yeah mans
phrases meals old man phrases
great winner yeah perfect that's what
shawn cantorwig should have done this
old-timey voice
yeah we're bringing you backstage guys
bts
all right we've got a number of atta boy
birds and goodwin neils
come on come on come on
[Music]
that's right great obviously a lot of
neighborhoods
you could just use the tag how did you
get it how'd you know
did you get it no that's there's nothing
i don't like about it how did you get it
uh great
[Music]
the problem with attaboy bird is you
don't really need attaboy bart's in good
one neil
you it's kind of a either or situation
well just options yeah we'll see
we'll go go with god it's so good
uh then two things oh come on
pretty good yes that's pretty good
really good good job good [ __ ]
[Music]
that's hong kong hey can you play that
okay
[Music]
that's so really funny it sounds almost
like south park
[ __ ] it's that's a really it's hong
kong jimmy comes home
aren't you in hong kong jimmy you're so
funny as a relationship
i just like it it's too good
that's thank you let's go over the names
again thank you
everybody just show me sean cantorwitz
uh fog labs at the boy
uh eric johnson banks can apologize
hong kong jim james ac bink's gonna
binky
um neil's old man phrases justin smith
was two
i don't know who did what but uh justin
smith
kennedy sasaki and
benjamin greenspan greenspan
green great great
[Music]
that's so funny um it's also i'm so
surprised by
how good quality everything is you can
make
anyone can make good music now if they
have if they have
a modicum of talent and 800 bucks
the thing the way it's like your phone
has more processing power than the
nasa have you seen that phone
that photo where a guy is holding all
this technology and everywhere
and the caption is your phone can do all
this yeah
yeah um the
it's that's me there's more processing
power on
will's computer than there was in
anything michael jackson ever used
yeah like thriller like it's all
knobs like literally like hard knobs and
like tape
yeah i thought i i read something that
the way they edited music
was literally yeah when i by the way
when i went to nyu that's how old i am
is we used to cut on tape are you
serious yeah that's why these phones
are [ __ ] i'll edit anything on my
phone because i'm like
this is a miracle yeah it's a mirror i
used to have to go to
there were three rooms you had to rent
it out
like you had to sign in and [ __ ] up
tomorrow at three
and then you'd run the tape over
literally a razor blade
then you'd have to loop it play it back
like the bg's documentary where they
loop the where they loop the
uh staying alive b
that's that's the world i'm from damn
play one of his old bands old man
phrases
beautiful um it's already a hit guys
now now that we're 79 minutes into the
podcast
i guess we should start now we've done a
lot of bookkeeping
maybe i cut out the wheelchair thing
because i don't want it to seem
self-aggrandizing it doesn't
i don't know i actually think it's
lovely okay because i just
it literally doesn't come across like
you okay i don't know because i don't
it what that's my point is like
i'm not even a i'm i'm talking i'm like
talking about it like i'm another person
like
oddly enough the the wheelchair story
for me just sounded like
the like of human interaction not like a
you guys i did anything like nothing
that's what is remarkable to me yeah
you good you good neil great now
speaking of
i don't even know george floyd
okay have you watched much of it yes
you don't find it unbearable well i
didn't say anything yet
okay uh i watched there's a channel on
co
that's you named cord which is my bad
cable
my off-brand cable just i'll just pay
i'll give you some money
no it's still i like it okay uh
and there's a channel that
they it's almost like a new version of
court tv one of them they have a channel
that's just
a surveillance footage of goodwill right
anyhow that's what he's almost serial
killed
programming estimate it's just cl it's
just close circuit television
so they have a channel called law and
something and they just play uh they
just have court proceedings
yep so the the trials on that i watch
for five minutes and then
i'm overwhelmed with emotion and i can't
watch yeah i don't i
haven't been able to watch
i'm just going by headlines yeah that's
the only thing i'm like good click bait
i like it
yeah tell me what happened what i'll say
is
everything i hear is no one's on his
side
he got nobody like no i don't think he
was well-liked to begin with
and then they're all like what the [ __ ]
were you the all the ca
i've never seen a bureaucracy turn on
somebody like this
it was almost like it's an internal
affairs investigation or something
it feels like we're not supposed to be
watching it almost
yeah like they're not i mean it makes
them look good
in as a municipality
like that they seem like there's just
people it's weird that
them agreeing that this was wrong
makes us feel uh
positive in a small way like wow they're
really coming together do you know that
we
i agree on reality with a police officer
it's so it just reminds me of being in a
relationship with someone who
cannot take responsibility and when they
do for a small thing
you're like you got a sucker you got it
look we've all been there bianca
no oh my god i forgot to tell you
speaking i don't even know what to call
her cat
in terms of the relationship to the show
but
she was on cat's a commercial director
was on set
directing a commercial they asked her
they're like the client doesn't want
that and she said over the
walkie-talkie that was open so everyone
could hear it she goes
the client can suck my dick from the
back oh
as a tribute to you suck my dick and
choke on it
she's always been because
a present today that's why we're
starting today
gift box it's a monthly fee
where a cat products cat really uses in
the wild
um yeah it's so sweet but also what the
[ __ ]
happened they all laughed oh thank god
yeah
um she got fired but they left i'm good
um
she it was fun um yes so i
i can't believe the amount of people
that are against the guy
and uh no i
now here's the well here's the thought i
had which is why
they're gonna have to pay all those
bystanders
meaning they could all sue they'll all
sue for emotional distress
and it's at the hands of the that same
police department
i i don't think that that's their plan i
don't think that
any i mean they're all under age and
[ __ ] like they're all
young people so they ca and they by the
way
seemed i don't think anyone were faking
from what i can do no
um so they're gonna have to pay them
good
um now did you hear the
the operator you know how there was like
an operator who saw it
uh the emt or the yeah like that
she was with the fire department she was
a white woman yeah and she
said hey i can administer yes and they
were like no
yes i remember her but she actually said
when she called them she says something
the effect of like
i don't know if i'm a snitch or what
but that's where like the karen [ __ ]
happens
that's where like what so she's not a
karen
no if okay someone no
well karen's
if a karen calls about a law being
broken
right when does she when does she stop
being a karen when is she
when is she just a [ __ ] righteous
person
and when is she when does she cross the
karen rubicon i think
karen means someone that's either in the
wrong
or not minding their own business
i think it's it's not i think it's not
running their own business i think it's
i think that's what it is or like in the
wrong like no
let me let me talk to your manager it is
their business but
right you know come on out of pocket
they're out of pocket
they're out of pocket and but i i
that was my thought it's like so she's
not a karen
it's one of those things but it's
philosophically easy she is
calling an author she says call me a
snitch or whatever at the beginning
of the call she said she might be a
karen to the police force
right she's not carrying to the world do
you know what i mean yes
but what i would say is the difference
isn't as major as everyone acts like it
is
it's a matter of do i like what you're
calling about or not i think you got it
do i like the transgression that you're
against
or not like
uh barbecue becky yes
i believe was wrong so the law she was
excited
they were in the place where they could
use charcoal oh yeah and they said
you're wrong and that's what she's like
i think it's very funny that there's a
place there's places in oakland that you
can't use charcoal
i like that like nah we don't use char
you're not like that's a no charcoal
zone
if you know do you barbecue no uh no so
it's because no i eat sofritas from
oh wherever the [ __ ] is dirt um no
there's just
charcoal like um bins where you put your
charcoals
do you know what's a bummer about
barbecuing what it's uh
all that smoke is carcinogen it's like
smoking a pack of cigarettes
really yeah in that it's one of those
things where i read it and was like
let me read that again it feels like
staying true
well there's a lot of chemicals in
charcoal yes and the lighter fluid
and the lighter fluid the now i don't
know if burning
wood fire barbecue smoke contains a high
level of polycyclic
aeromotic hydrocarbons which are known
to cause dna mutations repertoire
respiratory diseases
and even lung cancer this is some dr
sebby [ __ ] i'm like
um and look up is that all barbecue or
is that just
how about wood barbecue oh my god
wood type temperature and smoking
duration are among the factors that
could influence the quality yeah that's
of smoked fish
yep wood also but uh to the same degrees
i don't know but it's got to be less
than charcoal you know apparently
i heard a statistic so
i'm gonna just wing it but there's
higher levels of certain types of
cancers
in korea because they do so much
barbecuing i believe that
um but the cool thing is you all get it
because you're doing that
collective barbecue thing so that's
pretty cool guys it's is that racist
i don't think so see in court hi
i'm neil brennan i get sued all the time
for things
um so she's not a snitch but again
it's nice to see a police force
recognize now that's where you then
my next question logically is do they
get there without riots
i don't know look at the track record
the amount of behind the blue lining
that goes on i don't think so i don't
i gotta say i don't think so we i've as
much i
by the way i still wouldn't put it past
the jury to find a medicine oh no
i don't i don't think this is nice the
funny thing is
thank you for this isn't a slam dunk no
no video
everyone the police chief being like
this is wrong they're having criminals
come
and be like this is [ __ ] up the joker
testifies tomorrow
um and neil's like the narrative what
about the narrative
um i have a follow-up to to um
to uh parasite no please
here's what's great
me and my detractive were both right you
and your huh
my detractors that the that the rich
people they were all saying the rich
people were the parasites
and i was like no the poor people were
the parasites yes i remember you and
the director said they're both great so
we were both right
but i didn't attack anybody that's the
difference i didn't call people out do
you feel good
uh it's gonna be hard for this is gonna
be a real ayahuasca test
on on oscar night
whether what we'll see what happens guys
we're white knuckling this one
never tell you about the time i used the
term white knuckle on the breakfast club
and realized that it's an
only white person phrase oh i've said it
a million times are you sure
yeah white knuckling is but well
charlemagne doesn't have white knuckles
no no no one has white necklace of white
people
right that's why they none of them knew
what it meant it was one of them
terrifying racist moments that
so many white people deal with every day
white people i send you strength it's
stupid
um white people when they do talk shows
bianca it is a landmines everywhere
right
um okay so last
we record monday release tuesday today
we're gonna be late last tuesday were
released
and that day ugh
there's a maniac
stomps uh an old asian woman
right brandon elliott was this guy's
name she's he stomped uh don't even
even it's awful come on um come on
now and then people were going these
doormen should be ashamed of themselves
everybody should be sharing himself
then you find out who this guy is
maniac so that's where
call the cops comes in that's where my
theory of like
call the cops it's not up to a doorman
to be able to stop
a mom murderer
right the guy murdered his mom that's
one of those things where like
i'm not i don't everyone goes i would
have gone out
so now that you know he's a mom murderer
how if i'm one of the doorman i'm like
good i'm glad i didn't go out
i'm sorry that that happened to that
woman but i'd be why
so now it's my responsibility and this
is from
the homeless walker so the houses
home okay houseless home hunters
um house international house homey
hunters
yes uh the so uh what did you what do
you think of my theory
well i don't love it okay but i think
you're focusing on you're focusing on
the fact that they didn't come out where
i think most people
most people would intervene you know i
don't know
there's a our sample size is two people
and neither of them intervene there's
also that
kitty genovese case the classic yeah the
classic all the people watching yeah but
then when you
uh i watched a documentary on it i have
two and i've heard
40 theories about why no one intervened
i and i still don't
i don't beast is a woman who is getting
raped in a
uh in the 50s in an alleyway
with an earshot of probably a hundred
people and no one intervened
and there's a bunch of theories about
why
no one intervened and i don't even
remember what the theory the movie was
um there was a few but i
what i got from it was that and i think
it's happened to everybody
is that someone thinks someone already
called the cops
someone's already it's so like somebody
must have called because yeah it's gross
and it's heinous so someone has already
called the cops so
i've done that i've seen a car accident
or anything and i've called 9-1-1 and
every single time i have called
it's been a lot always in like an
emergency setting
uh they're like yeah we already have
like a bunch of girls
and they yell at you like what the [ __ ]
like why are you doing you're wasting
our time lady
i'm like okay they want you off the line
as good as possible
so i that is what i think
i don't
i don't blame the doorman
i hope i would have done something i at
the same time
[Music]
i mean i guess i would have when you see
the guy look i would have been like
yeah i mean i do have a bowflex too so
that's i know and you have this
assault gun
i can be very sarcastic just like
just read him what are you even
literally doing like what are you
doing what even are you right what even
are you like my soul
um ooh my soul uh
so i'd like to think i would have done
something
but i can't say i'm not doing anything
have you stepped in and i also what do
you do when you see a mom
murderer kicking a woman
have you ever stepped in have you ever
superman
a situation not superman nothing comes
to mind
i've called 9-1-1 for like a homeless
guy
laying in the middle of the sidewalk
that looks like injured what do people
need help
let's say it's not a dispute give me
more specific um
like i don't know this one guy's cane
got caught in the bus and was taking off
and i
ran in front of the bus and i was like
stop
no one else did anything which was so
weird
i'm like hello
theory of like ah some well i don't know
maybe
intentionally no he was kidding
well but that your brain will tell you
[ __ ] like so you don't have to think of
you ever have your brain telling
probably what it is
stuck in that bust whatever like maybe
by the way you said something really
funny last week that i didn't we need a
song for
bianca i'm sorry that was funny and
was uh when i said the mother
daughter mommy daughter sister that cdc
lady like as a mother
and you said it was like the holy
trinity you said some of the effect of
you you didn't exactly nail the landing
that's what you were going for and
that's very funny
i'm a comics muse i just like there was
some i you could have taken that in yes
turned it um thank you and uh
so your brain will tell you dumb [ __ ]
when you see something like that like
you ever
your first like you ever be waiting to
meet somebody and people come and be
like is that him and then you go
that doesn't look like him at all he's a
foot
taller than that you're like ah your
brain's like no that's him and you're
like
no that's not him you know what's
happening
like if you know when you're dating and
then just some people it just like
fizzles
yeah you don't hear from them
sometimes i've thought maybe he died
yeah
it's so funny to think that
that your brain thinks more like someone
else he died
than lost interest in you like well he's
probably dead
he's probably in a ditch somewhere um so
call the cops and if you're a cop
don't be a dirty cop i feel like okay
neil there's a little more to unpack
here why is calling the cops
a karen snitching thing if if there's an
actual right
what i'm saying is some karens yes
are justified but then they're not again
again but you don't know that until
afterward
you know what i mean like that it's easy
to say someone's a karen or not in
retrospect monday morning
caring is what happens um
is is that it's easy to say that
someone's karen
once you know all the facts but like
uh so that i call the cops if that's
happening
and that's again it's like if there's a
wild dog
what do you do that guy's a [ __ ]
clear
sociopath right but i will say men
like my example i don't know why a male
presence
does um change some [ __ ]
you know what i mean like even if you're
not like hey put up your dudes yeah if
you're just
there yeah that was yelling helps
yelling that old lady is not going to
take he knows if i was like
hey leave her alone like like i'm no
threat
but at least that guy looks kind of
official i don't know i just think yeah
the uniform helps yeah uniform health i
don't know even if you're not gonna
physically do anything just saying
something
i i think i don't know what does it do
to a man you think like if you
i think that i i had a
i remember when the lakers signed ron
artest
don't test our death and he and
somebody's like i just think he's going
to be bad for the team and he's
technical then i go he's not going to
get one technical
because of kobe there's like a thing
that happens
when somebody like kobe rides around
that you're like
i'm crazy like i know a
female celebrity who was getting death
threats
and instead of calling the cops she
called the crips
and the guy who was threatening her was
crazy
and but crazy people even crazy people
understand violence
and like i you don't need to write of
course of course
of course but even crazy people
understand violence
yeah like that's the thing that they'll
like the ca is intact
is following me but like hey hey hey so
yeah so there is a thing it's like uh
focuses the mind a bit that you might
you know i might
it's here's the story there was a
on set
it was on chapel show there was a black
dude working the show
he was like 55 i'm 30.
i'm in charge a little snappy and i
snapped at him one time and he just
looked at me like
you know i'll [ __ ] you up he didn't say
a word no but he
he just communicated like
yeah you're all whatever you are here
but it would be worth it
for me to [ __ ] you up to lose
this job's not that important to me
right my pride's more important than
this job
it's and his wife had a good job too
so he was sad he was like safety nets
like he was straight
i mean i've had weird outside
altercations with
men and then a stranger man comes to my
defense
and the entire situation is different
well
that's the good and bad part about
like why don't you it's the thing i was
saying about dalia or anybody like why
don't you
disavow them because i'm i don't want to
fight him
yeah when you step in it's like now we
have a problem yeah like there's
like i said there are there's a comic
who will could beat me up
right now no there's only one comedian
um uh so
yeah like so because i and then it's
like oh
yeah it's like you want some of this
i've got extra
right so would you like some that's the
problem there is a risk of
it'd be you're taking on your problem
like this one guy hit my car door
they were having some domestic violence
situation he hit my target while i was
sitting and it parked what good luck
so i was like hey man you hit my car
door what the [ __ ] and he's just
screaming at me he's like my wife's
crazy
and i'm not no that was you you opened
them like no it wasn't me i was just
he's screaming at me then a dude from
crosstalk is like
hey you need help i was like i need some
help actually can you help me
and he comes over he's towering over
this guy and he
i mean he punks him so badly like i
won't say everything that he says and
the guy
at the end of it i have his insurance i
have his license he's apologizing
he texts me i heard he renewed his vows
with this one he's stupid
that's how deeply you affected him but i
don't i he was like [ __ ] you i'm not
paying for that
yeah i was like and that's where it's
like
yeah you are it's that's where like the
jungle but it's also like
it's not the the law and then he goes
[ __ ] the law and then
then jungle law comes yeah which is i
will [ __ ] you up
i don't know what color he is um jungle
law comes and it's like
i'm bigger than you right so now what
yeah
just just animals yeah so
bless you but i'll [ __ ] you up
what do you want to do i will [ __ ] you
up
that's the great thing but that's why
male 1 tension gets resolved
and it's why men obviously there's
always like a young dumb friend that
hasn't gotten
knocked the [ __ ] out enough or has like
or likes that kind of
chaos but most guys love avoiding
altercation
yeah yeah just like uh no
yes it's too real there's like packs of
knuckleheads
occasion and like there's a few in every
one every ghost one of them
every club every night club has one pack
of knuckleheads yes and
always uh one in the pack of
knuckleheads will eventually go to jail
at some point
yeah but they all they stood with him
they went to his trial i'll come see
i'll put money in your commie
um speaking of something
matt gates putting something in put
something in something in something and
something
um he looks like he i mean that's one of
those things
like not him not the
absolute logo for a guy who [ __ ]
prostitutes uh underage or what i don't
know what he's accused of but uh 17 year
old
uh did you he did you see him on tiger
college yeah
that was uh it was great that was like
tucker went into full squint yeah he was
his mouth got very small
he went into a deep squint i made the
joke that he should have just put an eye
mask on
he would sell twenty full square just
like
in a sketch he would have put an eyelash
down um
it was so funny he's like she was a 17
year old woman
yeah that's not how debates work
he looks like he looks like an evil he
looks somebody said he looks like
uh the joker
i can't remember what he looks like he
looks like jack nicholson's joker's son
basically yes not even son nephew
because
when your eye brows cut off your eye a
little
mm-hmm you just look a little villainy
yep
also matt gates is attractive to
seventy percent of white women that's my
theory
real high yeah he's tall he's white he's
37
he's high status he's got money he'll
he'll send you a cash app also when it
was cash up i was like i mean
also just like guys what did you didn't
think you'd get anything for the
like you didn't that's the thing is like
you everything you do is on
there is a company i forgot what it's
called they are
they're a third-party company that's
with every
every cash app venmo paper they
there's a company i forgot the name but
they report everything you do to the irs
it's all there's not this isn't like
magic money being
transferred and there's no like paper no
it's
absolutely it's a thing it's a printout
yeah location time for
emojis why yeah emojis that'll be used
and that will be used in the court cases
and you send what did the emoji say
emoji mean miss
um it could mean like crying laughing um
yeah like he's in real trouble and he's
going to do real time
yeah and when you read it they're
they're investigating another
yeah the guy who's like green green
ridiculously [ __ ] corrupt he's real
like he's
taking people's licenses he was on john
oliver like
taking people's thrown away licenses
like
i will i'll be needing that i'll take
that from here thanks
leave me with the licenses guys i'll
turn the lights out don't worry
um then leave the safe open while we're
here greenville um
and then he's like oh i got these girls
and then they went and [ __ ] gates
i'm like an indictment states that
greenberg used his access
as an elected official to look up
information about a girl between the
ages of 14 and 17.
to produce a false identification
document and to facilitate his efforts
to engage in commercial sex acts
oh my god that's so bad maybe he wanted
her to be
overaged yeah he's just okay let me make
you fake
that's a new one like that's a reverse
i'm like
hey mister will you buy us beer or like
getting a fake id like no
i'm gonna make you a fake id i'm gonna
make you think then it's legal for me to
have sex with you like
no to who it's a fake id
um he gates has denied having sexual
relations with underage girls paying
women for sex or visiting sugar daddy
websites
he said that he has been generous with
girlfriends in the past
and is never engaged in illegal conduct
uh
yeah he also said i'm not a monk which
is very funny
yeah like no you're you're not even
you're not really a man
i don't even think you're a law-abiding
citizen so there's a big but that's just
they play this thing about
that my dad's being extorted and like no
no he's not
also the extortion thing against his dad
is very weird
really strange it's about a missing a
guy who got
kidnapped in iran by the government and
they presumed dead
but they wanted to pay money
they wanted him to pay money for them to
investigate it
and then matt gates would get the credit
it was like what
what yeah it was like a bunch of
drug people we're like hey man
so we're gonna get you know what he was
getting high when they thought about it
you know he's missing so all right
we tell what's that dude's name is
senator
we get his dad dude um
the the best is when he's like me and
you and your wife and
me and my then friend i don't remember
i've never had dinner tucker carlson
dinner's not something i eat you
remember that's one of the
strangest interviews i've ever done uh
it was great um
trump guys you're not gonna believe this
donald trump did some
illegal [ __ ] you guys um what he did
he basically hit people with
the old renewing the the auto renew
the ottawa new aka handy yeah a handy
cleaning app
um people would donate
and they would if they wanted to donate
40 dollars
the auto renew button must have been
confusing or something right
so everyone was auto renewing first
every week
every week wow i thought it was a month
no it was we
can i so i was reading the article this
guy
who's on a little less than a thousand
dollars a month
uh salary or you know like financial
situation
500. he donated five hundred dollars of
his
thousand dollar monthly finances and
then
after in a month three thousand dollars
in a month
they got him for three thousand that's
wild
i don't feel bad right this is th this
is why he won't win again
because if you are directly can't [ __ ]
up he did but he didn't
yeah you can't that's brazen
that's funny that's so like uh you can't
shade that you can't go there trying to
make me look good
no dog it's an auto renew thing this is
just a [ __ ] better business bureau
right he's the first president that's
going to get in trouble with the better
business business
he's not going to get impeached but he's
going to get a ton of the
troubleshooters the channel five the
eye on seven on your side yeah the seven
on your side are gonna come
uh but you know why would you donate
over 50 of your income for the month
because
he's a because he's the kind of dick
you'd like to be to
to elitist liberals that's
it because emotionally he's the
so many people's avatar it's crazy it's
just like
so you're going to go against your
bottom line yeah if
it means i'm better than black people
that's what
a lot of this [ __ ] is reach yeah if it
means i'm better than black people or
mexicans or whatever
then yeah no no price is too high yeah
no pre it's like do i get to you're
going to create a club that guarantees
i'm better than blacks and latinos
and arabs and asians and
of course russians part of asia yeah
so that's all it is and you're going to
stick it to the libs
and make them seem like their reality is
fake
yeah double ought to renew me twice
you can't auto renew me enough based on
this deal
um yeah i but that's this to me is like
a bridge too far
like that's where people go you know
what he might be i don't know
i don't believe it this is maybe
convincing the most
yes trump trump yes trump because these
will people go like he ripped us off
and all that i loved you yeah yeah
that's what will happen
um and now it's an evangelicals thing
yeah it's like what happened to
jerry falwell and jim big and all those
people in the 80s and 90s but
don't you if you think about it i mean
church is auto renewed weekly
it is uh if you
[Music]
you but you got to hand it in right oh
yeah you still got to hand it out what's
it called the basket
the basket they have a special term for
it called the basket
basket um uh so
yeah this is the kind of thing that that
but and he's like an evangelical
and he's the god oh [ __ ] he's a
televangelist yeah and he's the guy and
he's also there also
it's a double he does double duty i mean
in some ways they're all the god but
he's
really the god he really is yeah in some
respects but apparently now
he has to refund i think to the tune of
a hundred and twenty two million dollars
and if i know anything with donald trump
he done spent that money
he done spent it all on gold leaf [ __ ]
that
is by the got it by the yard and it's he
got a deal and it's not actually gold
and anyhow you're not getting your money
back um
[Music]
evanston you know what evanston no was
gonna
it's like in likely first chicago suburb
oh yes yes it is chicago evanston
approves reparations for black residents
racial equality and inclusion athletes
uh it's pretty incredible it's great
it's this is where this is like not like
this is the problem reparations
this is going to be the speed bump or
the
hindrance to it being pleasing to
everybody which is it'll grant
qualifying
households up to 25 000 for down
payments or home repairs if
they if they or
a member of their family lived in
evanston in a certain period
okay um that's fine yeah it's but it's
you know it's not unqualified it's not
like
let's get to evanston and get this money
it's like no it feels very uh
1919 and 1969. if you were
black uh because they they have
housing discrimination like proven
housing discrimination
this is where i have a theory that roy
wood may do a
daily show piece black people should sue
uh white people for uh
antitrust things for like
monopoly [ __ ] because it's
wrong like do you know what i mean like
the whole thing is rigged
[ __ ] everything but you're gonna sue
everybody
i mean [ __ ] it bianca this will be a
good tester
it's pretty limited it's 10 million
dollars i
25 25 dollars you have to live in
evanston to get the money that's what
i'm curious about do you have to like
move to evanston
or maybe you just get it your family had
to live there
right they had to live there but is that
now you're entitled
uh it's
it's weed money which is super cool so
it's super cool
dank money um the bills are actually
danker than normal bills
stop saying uh it will grant households
for down payments or homework but
is it in evanston we don't know
oh all right so you got to reside in
evanston at the time of
disbursement of funds so you could leave
yeah but you have to own well maybe you
could rent but you got to spend it on
it can only be spent it's not cash so it
can only be
spent on home or i guess you could
repair it you could flip a house
get it get a house in evanston i'm sure
it's lovely what's up what's this
50 minimum uh yeah
that i live near there you did wilmette
yeah that's where
northwestern is i don't get it when did
you live there
when i say i live in chicago oh you live
that's called the north shore
no this is there's a water body water in
michigan
near evanston on it's on the water
there's the beach
are there black people there there's
like 20 black people
okay so or it's 17 or something um
but is it expensive they were they were
scary i'm kidding
is it is it like a it's you know
it's like not it's not like the hood
it's not like
it's like just middle class it's just
like a developed city sounds like
something oh yeah yeah
like north western's there it's like you
know it's a
it's it's like a small
i don't know what the 70 000 people
how many people wow um
74 000. oh that's a good one
[Music]
um
[Music]
that thing on the right what what is
that it's a baha'i
uh rich white people in wilmette uh
but they're midwestern rich white people
so they will not buy nice cars honestly
they're all rich and they're like we
save our money or our
catholics um
[Music]
uh what's the so p basically the um
church membership nationwide oh the
church attendance is different
church yeah membership is the first time
it's not a majority
meaning of eligible people yeah of
americans
is it christian catholic just christian
i think it's
every church membership i think uh
oh it's everything i mean
there's an upside and downside of this
what's the downside
downside is their people have no moral
compass well that's true but can't you
get a more compass i mean i wasn't
raised religious
at all and i can that's the thing is you
can
it's like i did a i did a uh
daily show feature about um
[Music]
that they need jesus like republicans
need jesus they used to it used to be
ballast
for their behavior like well we need to
kind of at least appear
right and now they still claim it
because they need
evangelical votes but they don't they
don't they don't even really
pretend anymore no they're like [ __ ]
underage girls and
doing this and it's basically like
are we all voting for the same way
well yeah i just it's the this gets into
the thing of
religions cause more wars than anything
and i would argue it's also prevented
more punches in the face
like it's there's it's not all bad like
it's oppressive
it's it is like oppressive in a million
ways
but there's [ __ ] that's good for society
which is why if you look at like the ten
commandments
and the the kind of bill writes
they're not that similar but just it's
basically the laws
yeah it's like the joke that i've never
done is like
there was a government and they had laws
and they were like
we need a sky cup how do we get this
let's say god wants this also and then
they write up this thing
and it's like hey we're fine with murder
um so i don't
think it's all negative uh
no but i i think it's positive
no oh well the lack of religion okay
what's your argument for most people not
going to a church because it's not
the the atheism thing is creeps but it's
not creeping that quickly
no i don't think you have to be an
atheist and i also don't think you have
to be part of a church i mean i
grew up not religious at all yeah my
mom believes in like she's a grew up
catholic and
my on my dad's side uh
my grandma's muslim but it's not
it's not in any part of my childhood the
only time i ever went to church is when
i stayed the night at a particular
person's house
on a saturday and they're like we we're
going to church which is so funny when
you think about it
now someone would sue you if you took
your their kids if you made their kid
after a sleepover go to church it's
you don't even it's fine we're gonna
throw hands
i know at least i would sit in sunday's
home like this
below you would go to sunday school well
i was a kid
but with your friend yeah
oh i always [ __ ] i'm like [ __ ] like my
parents
wouldn't be able to pick me up early
enough before they went to church yeah
we lived a mile away and they wouldn't
drop me off so
it's just like there were a lot of fake
kidnappings they're really it was
it was the golden age you know that was
an entirely fake stat made up by adam
walsh's dad
what no so
i remember adam walsh yeah the guy on
the americans and then john walsh
became the host guy's dad
guy's son got kidnapped murdered
dad becomes an advocate somehow parlays
that into hosting
america's most wanted right um word wear
a leather jacket
um and a t-shirt and uh
they would say that there were hundreds
of thousands of kidnappings a year
and and then if you dug down
it was like under a thousand
yeah it's not it wasn't it it wasn't a
common problem at all
and they lied about it that's so weird
they lied about it because he
it was i don't think it was like
directly as good just take john walsh
out of it
between 350 fewer than 350 people under
the age of 21 have been inducted by
strangers in the united states per year
between
2010 and 2017. that's so few
for how many for how much the amount of
terror it creates
i know and in the 80s it was like do you
know
like does a child go missing every 40
seconds like where the [ __ ] do you come
up with that
um yeah those like there was one
kidnapping stats by year
the crimean united states robber and
assault is down
if you're ever scared on the street
remember that crime is down
to 1960s levels yeah so think about how
scary you'd be
walking around in 1965. i will say
though for a
woman it's a woman it's always 19. it's
uh
it's always 19. it's always 20 21.
um murder and rape is down
a good amount um
valiant crime down uh violence against
children two to seventeen is going down
i think too quickly but yeah it's
updated kids
uh look up go back to kidnapping go back
to the
okay how many uh
i got that one what age gets oh that's
interesting one age gets kidnapped the
most let's guess hold on
i'm gonna go with nine and i don't know
i'm
feeling eight or nine i was i was gonna
say eight
twelve twelve and older why they could
do something about it do you know what i
mean like it feels like you would want
to
throw hands you're going to have your
hands full i mean
obviously if you don't feed them they're
not going to when a child is under 12
years there's no second guessing
fellow how many kidnappings 1980s
you know why it's 12 and older because
sex no because it's
uh it's more vague as to why they're
missing
oh well by the way most of them are
custody battles most of them are father
yes
uh no no top top top most dispelled
kidnap myths
uh do little to allay parents fears
click on that please
that's [ __ ] it's fine all right the
point is
all those stats were [ __ ] um
uh yeah like the problem is it's so
sensationalized too
well it is terrifying no it's totally
terrifying but
when one person gets kidnapped i mean
we're still talking about jean-vinay
ramsay
that's fine i don't think there's
something wrong with bringing attention
to kids being kidnapped
and there is like trafficking issues
around the world you know so
it's not like why are we still talking
about this well i don't think i think
trafficking is mostly like
the philippines and [ __ ] like that like
like
dirt poor and you it's it's you might
not be right where most trafficking's
from
where most victims of human trafficking
it's like i
thought that worse the economy yeah no
no 100
and sometimes i mean my stepmom's
filipino and she
100 when she goes to the philippines she
says she'll see
very rich white men with like groups
of kids and a few times she's
boom estimates uh that suggests that 50
000 people are trapped in the united
states each year most often from mexico
and or yeah but they're in the united
states right but
if they're in the united states that
means they're also everywhere
it's like a hub no no for sure yeah i'd
get and obviously there's
they're going from poor to rich right
um yeah
uh terrifying should be stopped but it's
rare
not human trafficking that's a whole lot
weird it's like that's another issue but
then
this the kidnapping thing was i'm gonna
take a ten-year-old boy
and torture and murder him and the
amount of that
i think is incredibly small right
like i don't know him i mean it happens
at a lot of good wills
but i don't know him and i'm gonna like
i'm gonna find him and put him in my van
or whatever is
i think that's [ __ ] i think that's
not i think it's incredibly rare but you
know what's weird we all as kids and
maybe not
as maybe not men as much i mean i don't
know i think boys are preyed upon
also but everyone has a scary story of
someone
doing something very creepy when they're
a kid stranger-wise
like your mom the flashers yeah i have
so many uh so i'm trying to think if i
have
any i don't have
no one was interested in me as a victim
from the bad body yeah i mean there was
this before i ended both like
um this is just wiffle ball i had body
buy a wiffle ball back there
uh but yeah so
it's a fake set i don't even know how we
got on that um
from church
well no well that's the thing of is
shirt is a little bit of church
good for a society i just think
that church in a vacuum is
great on paper church seems lovely and
okay cool like goals it's like largely
not about hate you want to talk about
most of the [ __ ]
it just all the attention goes to gays
and all that stuff but it's also like oh
there's a lot of soup
there's a lot of community yeah there's
a lot of community uh there's a lot of
soup
there's a lot of community i just mean
you don't need
church with for a moral compass i wasn't
raised in
anything close to a church at all no
almost no church influence in my life
yeah and i know a lot of people like
that like even in europe most
it's not a really religious place
anymore and
yeah you know what i mean you can find
countries that have
grown out of like religion being the
moral compass yeah and they don't
they're not gone to [ __ ]
so yeah it's european socialism
it's like the fear of europe and it's
like no it's fine it's eating
louis used to do a joke about going to
harlem and he's like just people working
and walking to
home but in your head it's like harlem
it's an establishing shot of harlem
um uh
what's about the florida lake thing oh i
just thought it was
not funny but basically there's this
this reservoir of toxic wastewater
and uh it's it's breaking
and it's uh everyone is being evacuated
in the area
it might [ __ ] up tampa
um they're trying desperately to plug
the hole but it just it
reminds me of the fact that no one wants
to deal with environmental issues until
there's a looming disaster they're
trying to fill this whole if this hole
breaks it goes into
um there's chemicals in the water that i
yeah i don't fully understand that it's
just it's gonna
poison the area yeah it's going to
poison
uh the water that has like a whole
ecosystem
that animals are living in and they're
thriving very close to this place where
the waste water is from like an old
plant
from the 60s or something and they can't
they don't know what to do with the
wastewater
this is where women might be
better governors than men i mean there's
probably
millions of places but this is this
strikes me as like
gotta think women i i had a thought the
other day actually that
what your what your body what you're
forced to do by your body
informs your morals and your
sense of a bunch of [ __ ] like women have
a you have a wastewater plant
you have you have a way to do a bunch of
[ __ ] you have a bunch of [ __ ]
that you have to do in terms of upkeep
that i will never have to do
yeah and it makes you more responsible
and
makes you more fastidious and attention
to detail and all that [ __ ]
that you are i think
men would think naturally and it could
be estrogen it could be but i don't
think they're unrelated
no or also when you think this could
poison
a whole area you think of children you
think of family of course immediately
like the golf course not the course
but it's it's the way guys would run
it's like
i don't know it's like a guy with his
first apartment right like
something's [ __ ] up about the ceiling
i don't i just try not to pay too much
attention to it
i'm just gonna ignore it how about that
i'll ignore it and we'll see what
happens yeah so that's what most of
these things
state of emergency and they're
scrambling and trying to pump it and
trying to
figure out what to do with it it's be i
don't know it
seems it just seems like
someone probably told somebody this
could be a problem
at some point in the past of course but
it's like we don't have the money
everything's too remote everything's
chernobyl did you watch chernobyl yeah
everything is now we should we it's the
spider meme of
uh oh yeah everything that's happened
chernobyl is a [ __ ] message amazing
um chernobyl
craig mason the guy who wrote it also
wrote scary movie
no yeah no he agreed that's
great i also liked how everyone was
british and they were russian
we buy it that's the old that's what
that's you know what
some colonialism not so bad thank you
colonialism
funny thank you uh godmother of
of colonialism queen queen mum
um chet hanks had a tough week
right after i said he could be the tom
hanks i know
you you cursed him with yourself i
cursed you i put him on
i gave him put him on the summer jam
screen and he
[ __ ] up him almost immediately i said
he could be on
in fact he had done it we recorded that
monday by tuesday afternoon before the
podcast aired
he had already come out that he punched
his girlfriend
and had a bloody eye and yeah
um yeah
just that's one of those things where
why did you have a pot why is she
wearing
where she had big bird's coat in her
hands
i got a piece he's got a piss
she's she's got a piss she's she's got
big bird's coat
she's got a pot and
that's one of those things where
it's like don't this is of course he had
a black girl
girlfriend has a like but they're always
on
red carpet oh really i didn't know that
like the grandparents like
tom hanks yeah they like bring the baby
she's so cute you know
i didn't know i don't fall closely i'm
not gonna this is
i love hot goss this is bottom tier
celebrities this feels
what is this now that's
completely dependent on his star status
what do you mean that it's not good goss
no no no no i like shitty good guys
but you what do you think is shitty
about this uh
he's you know it's it doesn't stop with
the
uh the fake jamaican he loves it too
much
now it's a white voice like he loves the
attention so much and
also has so many skeletons in his closet
i just that's such a bad the like
person i thought he doesn't have that
many skeletons he said the guy
said the guy who tried to want him on
i wanted to book him one of those
personal appearances last week
no it just feels so messy and not
a story that we're seeing cctv a footage
of or something we just oh [ __ ] this
celebrity got us oh we didn't even
put down sweetie and no we didn't quavo
and we can't care but what i'm at least
that is them living their life and we
are pulling back that
what is you know what i got from sweetie
and cueva
i what i was trying to figure out is why
they were fighting over a defibrillator
yeah it was a weird fighting over a
giant orange suitcase
it's like did you did you must have been
biden give you the nuclear
the football what's the fight about
cueva
who of course you may know i know
from uh the john the madden 2019
campaign that i did and he was good and
i believe sweetie came to set
and i didn't know who she was but i just
thought that girl's [ __ ] gorgeous
she's so pretty i love sweetie yeah uh
and i live sweaty
yeah i wouldn't trade places with the
migos
no like i even when it was happening it
was like
this looks this is going to be hard to
figure out
because they're going to have to break
there's just there it's
it's like hip-hop long longevity is
impossible
they were as hot as can be yeah
but there's three of them they're like
cousins
they like each other
and but but it's it yeah like
it just seemed hard um well you want
some
hot gosh i love it i love it so there
was a guy
named uh
i don't know he's just this guy he has a
show it's like internet show with
puffy son and he was interviewing
sweetie
and he asked a question um it was kind
of a gross question he was just saying
hey you know cuevo's treating you right
he's treating you good oh the anal
question
did like he's like he put it no not you
know he just said you know he's treating
you good
he sticks his tiny butt like he's just
being dumb he sets up the
question it's kind of a rude question
but she's fine with it
and then he goes if to treat to show
cuevo that you appreciate him
yeah who are you gonna bring in as a
like third person in a threesome and
then she goes like
i'm gonna let him choose the thing that
we're gonna do twisting but like
basically like
we're gonna do with a guy yeah it was a
good job it was great
um anyways why did
the amigos go find that guy in a club in
atlanta and beat him up
oh that's funny for that interview
that's that's him very funny that's one
of those things of like
you know i'll [ __ ] you up it's the same
we have a theme this episode that's like
star and buck wild in 2002
or three made a aaliyah joke damon dash
just went and
got him [ __ ] up and they got fired
oh my god the joke did not go well well
you can't really make an alia joke
yeah especially at that time yeah it was
fresh
it was like still a little too soon yeah
even now
he's the she's the sky black
female abraham lincoln not yet
lincoln you couldn't you could only joke
about like three years ago
uh johnny carson used to say like you
cannot get a laugh on lincoln
assassination jokes for
some reason really it it's new that it
gets laughs
no i swear to god it's new i swear to
god it's new
funny people are people just have weird
things like no i don't want to talk
about that okay here's one
um adele had a birthday party and it was
titanic themed
and all these british people awake
and i was like is it um
the yeah she can afford it she's
quite well to do
so yeah this i don't like oh what d d d
yeah dmx is not doing good
um has 15 kids but i didn't know
um and he
there were dudes doing the the rough
rider [ __ ] in front of the hospital
yesterday damn i love that and um
and i'm just so
he can't die that would be a really
tough
that he feels like a
i'm sure to a lot of people it's like
some old man
yeah but most people like that's when we
tell gen z like
hold the [ __ ] up right but also like
it's very hard to listen to rough riders
anthem and not be like
oh this is the hottest [ __ ] i've ever
heard i'm gonna [ __ ]
kill somebody right now this is so i'm
sorry i mean it's hard not to get looped
into it it's hard not yet
it's so so good it's makes you talk
fight somebody yes it makes you want to
[ __ ] up
a radio even the beginning don't donate
before that there's like
oh yeah don't know what that is by the
way
is that a neptuni swiss beets swiss no
okay that sounds very
swiss beets 16 years old
what do you mean i believe we look that
up swiss beets rough riders anthem age
uh 16 years old yeah
well he started making tracks 16. a year
later he sold his first
it's 17. it's
incredible he doesn't get enough credit
for it he sure doesn't and is one of the
fathers of versus him and him and yeah
well they were the first guys to do it
yeah they were the first guys um
he also did one with just place one
night that was on instagram like
for two three years ago where they went
back and forth
um versus is so good i didn't watch the
one
yo can i tell you first of all steve
harvey wouldn't shut the [ __ ] up
and i love steve harvey somebody had a
video of steve harvey not
like a old woman being like oh yeah i
saw that which is like
because every story was someone wrote
like i'm done hearing these fake made up
stories
about like so steve has some like
something to say in between
they were they were it just felt like
that one
family member that just tells me let me
grab that mic
that thing let me wait the person i
can't he was like
and i heard that story and i wrote down
and then i got on my bike i mean the
amount of times he got on a bike and
it's like a fake getting rejected by
girls left and right their stories were
annoying they were annoying he was
saying that the songs reminded him like
okay ron eisley would
isabel was singing songs like man when i
first heard that story it was just like
when i first heard that story
this story was one this blah blah blah
it was so many like
steve reminiscing stories but we heard
we just didn't hear as much from the
people
the eisley brothers earth win and fire
who both of them
sound exactly the same as their
recording
it's so now you can appreciate it more
they recorded them like live
performance well first i'm sure they did
them live yeah
but even like the way the backup vocals
are
they sound like someone singing backup
vocals at a venue
yes so it's like you can do dance of
september and like honey
yeah same like it was this it was they
were already set they like planned for
it
they they planned like you the album
you're gonna love
sounds exactly like these guys singing
just standing in a [ __ ] room it was
so good but
i really wanted to hear more from earth
wind and fire and
eisley bro the isley brothers you know
just got a lot of [ __ ] to say earth
i prefer wind earth has some
wild stories but like the i
i think ron eisley said they were
telling random facts
like one of the songs i think maybe this
little heart of mine like
in the 60s that hit came in the 60s they
have
like 30 albums 45 albums all these hits
no 45 like platinum no 29 platinum
albums yeah
i believe that it's crazy these crazy
stats so you're in the presence of
living legends i can still do it not you
know we wheel them out and clap for them
they can still do it yeah they're still
good yeah
and the songs are so [ __ ] amazing
everyone likes these songs
here's a question and it's steve harvey
how do you feel
about old people
kind of profiling and stunting and
posing
i gotta say i don't like it there's a
bunch of
pictures of ronnie eisley on instagram
today
like in a fur way you don't want him to
be wearing like a sweatsuit
i don't know i don't know i don't know
you're weird though because you don't
like when people do anything off-brand
i right but what i'm saying is john
eisley this is
old dude at the club do you know what i
mean
right but i'm saying it can the old dude
to the club
i don't know what i wanted to dress like
but but
something about the guy with the
straight hair always made me
uncomfortable
leave it leave earth alone is that earth
is that you
um and i like a suit and they can still
move
well i like the way steve's dresser than
the hat and the glasses like just wear a
suit
they're all wearing suits neal right but
the one guy on the far right described
his outfit to me
uh ving rhames he's being as
stacy adams
like the headband and the well he's the
guitarist too
well guitarists can
uh yeah i just don't know how
i believe after a certain age you
shouldn't try i can't explain it
just where where's the first of all that
outfits wild
oh that's so wild um the
just wear something a little less i
don't mind
go back to the old the last one i love
the way earth wind fire looked
back in the day they looked amazing this
is amazing they look like
they look like parliament whether they
were i don't know who came first
probably
they came first um i don't know um
hard to say i don't like
why not dress like that which one the
either one if we're gonna if they're
trying you want them to
wear this [ __ ] well if they're trying to
be cool let's [ __ ] if you're really
about that life
no that's like that scene and i'mma get
you sucker where the guy gets out of
jail and he's still wearing pimp clothes
yeah and his age and they're like
brother you've been shopping at the
goodwill like no
um no they would have been they would
have been ripped for
like do you need the paisley suit is my
question
can you not wear there's three paisley
suits out of six
like steve's got the shark skin
monochrome
color blocked blue on blue on blue on
blue
you take his hat and glasses off i'm all
with it
okay and the straight hair guy
but when does someone earn the right to
dress however the [ __ ]
i don't and it feels like and i'm not
saying you're let him dress how he wants
i'm saying one are you like yeah
whatever you do
good great fantastic certain guys like
sly stone
i don't like to see people have to make
the transition
from like what do you what
should you wear as an old performer it's
like a lot of them wear
uh bedazzled [ __ ] do you like the way uh
george clinton dresses now i don't know
he's just the same
with like way too many lanyards
uh i like what i'm seeing so far well
that's pretty cool but that's a
transition
no like a can you that one head to toe
outfit will maybe don't you touch it
just outfit
it's all hell oh it's a lot of villains
hillary clinton
just to outfit i like it i like what i'm
saying you just want
don't just stay say on brand or i just
don't it's like what's the premise of a
paisley suit
because it's not they look it's not
outer funk
it's not outer space funk it's a blend
of like
okay and also they're they're they're
they
are there with other whatever
funktastic people so they don't wanna
mariah carry the situation right but
george clinton
there's a way to do your thing do you
know what i mean not be like
i know what you mean it's i'm i either
want
what george clinton's wearing which is
excellent
it's excellent or um which is better
maybe the best outfit i've ever seen are
you going to come in this outfit i don't
i'm i hate to come are you okay so he's
getting clicked guys
you guys it's bianca this is my final
announcement to make
that's maybe the best outfit i've ever
seen it's good um and his old outfits
were great
it's like an update of an old outfit a
paisley suit
a shark skin paisley suit is like well
i don't know what you're doing you look
like a guy who owns a cigar shop right
down to the top bottom split
i'm just seeing the other one yeah that
one just seeing how they get updated
you don't think they're pretty related
to what they're wearing now
no not even close i don't think that a
that a that uh
not enough is for you not a paisley suit
is not the modern version of that
it's more like black churchy
uh it's blood trick it's black church
slash
entrepreneurs conference so if you i
don't i
it's like nah that's not music to me so
if you go watch
west side connection in concert you want
them all to be sagging
and wearing like i wanted
i don't want to see too short in skinny
jeans do you know what i mean like
it's like that i don't either actually
it's like the
how i like you yeah daffy duck
be them be daffy duck as close as you
can get
like if it's gotta work yeah okay
that's all i'm saying it's very specific
while we're on the subject i have
another thing that i wanna
get into which is moving on when women
this is a useless observation
hit it this was big in the 80s and 90s
[Music]
sometimes in pictorial
spreads of naked women sometimes they'll
be wearing
sneakers like a centerfold yeah
and i think it's so gross
and dumb and not at all sexy
and i've never understood it like are
you working out
i'm going to work that that ass i just
it's just like are you running away from
me
also it's going to hurt at some point to
get a
foot shoe like on my shoulder you know
you know how i like to [ __ ]
um just take ladies shoes off
when you come to the neil brennan photo
naked photo shoot thank you
i almost like i'm just like no yeah
something good
yes we gotta send you know we gotta send
some some good
ayahuasca vibes towards him we sure do
uh
but it makes me sad yes well it's sad
because
it's like a guy who real it's like a
mental health thing
it's a poverty thing it's a broken home
thing
it's like a lot of [ __ ] conspired
against him early
and he was he was like
pain yeah like all like better it all
was
and it's just a sad system
this is he is the system and everyone
who loves dmx
especially growing up understands all of
like he put so much of his pain in his
music
so there's that connection you know he
had that connection that like
corn and those dudes have with their
fans or like lincoln park where they're
like
i there's something happening here i
don't like
not for me but dmx was like not for me
but
like for like was for me but i wasn't
like
i'd drive around with my dad like i'd
tell my dad to [ __ ] off and like but i
did it
um one of my favorite chapel show
appearances
um he dave just kept hitting buttons
and we basically just made him do his
greatest hits and it was great
for as far as i was concerned because i
always wanted hits
i wanted the music to be hits and if we
got dmx
don't want to hear the new one i want to
hear right rough ride his anthem
and in the middle of it he yelled at his
producer
and it's very funny that's right because
he's like what the [ __ ] are you doing
he like played the wrong song he played
the wrong version he's like where's the
[ __ ] beast coming on
um you make him sound like an old
armenian
he but he's one of the greatest rock has
a good observation which is
pretty much every great hip-hop artist
could be
an animated cartoon character vocally
which is like yeah yes yep yeah
absolutely
um
she didn't even claim she made a million
dollars in six hours she
truly showed the receipt yeah and uh
she made a million
something in six hours a million
uh a million thirty
in six hours and uh here's the thing i
didn't know about her
she's just turned 18. no that's why i
didn't know that
i thought she was like 21 or something
neil you were subscribing like
well i didn't know i tried to subscribe
a few months ago
and they kept saying no results and i
was like check again
uh didn't know she was 18. and i'll say
this
i'm even more impressed by her now
because the fact that she went on
television at 15 or 16
dropped four hooks in one dr phil
appearance
is still one of the greatest feats i've
ever seen on television
[Music]
i don't need you to agree you're just a
real
i feel like you're a fan i am i'm
literally literally
and i think have you liked her instagram
post
i don't think i ever have okay i do
follow her though okay
it was creepy but no it's okay totally
because i was like all i see here is
you owe the government a lot of money
leave me alone that i'm matt gates i'm
the match gates of this podcast
no no no no i said when i see people
posting how much they make
all i see is stay away from me with all
that government business
meaning they're just going to tax her
yes she has to like sort that out
she's just no doubt that's a good
problem to have
no it's not um trust me it's a person
who makes a million dollars in six
hours
naked and sneakers covered that what's
mommy parade mommy parade
is that mommy's in england egypt just
held an astonishing real-life mummy
parade
through the streets of cairo to
celebrate the opening of a new museum
i see if there's any other photos
because
[ __ ] just mommy parade is such a
sketch
idea no it's great like uh like pitching
like
i have a sketch called a mommy parade
what was that one that you
liked that my silence
what was it my silence the greatest of
all time the greatest book title of all
time for a sketch
mice island um spade always does
uh would always go it's a caveman who's
afraid of caves
um the yeah but mommy parade is such a
sketch idea and
such a weird thing to do i want to see
my
mommy pray mommy i don't know mommy
mommy
um i don't know if horse looks terrified
if you can see the mummies or they're
just
if you can see the mummies or they just
kind of come by in the sarcophagus
but neil you date her neil you're
absolutely right i would date her
um she might even break up with me
[Music]
she's got a jawline that could break up
with me like she's like
you think i won't break up with you you
think i'm like gonna play the game
with you where i try to figure out if
you're losing interest
women say i'm hard to read which i don't
see yeah you were me
you were a uh in lobby of cheesecake
factory you know buzzer the whole time
it surprised me um
not anymore though uh i don't think you
can see them up
or wait are those the mommies those are
this one that
uh you know how like in in china they'll
have the missiles in russia they'll have
like
a military parade joe biden said old
this is his parade
where he just has mummies come by to
salute and he salutes them because he's
so close to being an actual mommy
himself corn pops there
by the way biden and
trump had more plastic surgery than
combined than an entire cat bine had
so much plastic surgery it's [ __ ]
biting before now he's the king of the
facelift and
i plugs have to before that's a doctored
photo that's
that's not even well the one on
2007 when he's with like he was shaggy
he had a ton of work done well that's
just the that's just the fox that's
the that's the eyebrow threading that
but he had all of it pulled back
like trump without spray tan and hair
plug
henry [ __ ] funny he looks like
he looks like putin basically putin's
had a putin has so much botox oh before
and after
putin just he's just got a ton of botox
his face got big russian
oh my god he's a smooth man and he now
it doesn't
[ __ ] move he's so smooth yeah his
forehead doesn't move
he like god they the uh i didn't even
think
male politicians would get plastic
surgery i don't know why
tons of them i think morgan murphy had a
great tweet recently which is uh this is
frightening uh i can't wait till this
summer
or as i call it um
[Music]
celebrity surgery unveiling season
because it's
a summer after hello
yeah putin's wild putin's like come on
you have no smooth he is a cat eye
um very funny yeah uh
so i mean you want to talk about rest in
power kings mommy parade
literally rest literally in power
literally in kings what would our parade
be in america like what's our known
fourth thing
food just like [ __ ]
orient fries snickers and all that [ __ ]
and and denial here comes denial
this could be a longer schedule i can
get it you get it doc watch
i only date women who do their own taxes
if you're sitting on an elephant
life is either going extremely well but
you got any dog watches
i watched the last cruise
which uh was about the cruise ship
the princess whatever that had all the
covey cases early
oh wow that and it
shouldn't work it's not long oh it's
good it's like
not even an hour it's like 50 something
like 53.
and um it's better than it should be but
that's the great uh
thing about everybody videotaping
themselves all the time and people on
on on boats have n and that are
quarantined have
nothing to do um can they be outside of
their rooms
no they can't be at the pool no
no they could not leave their rooms
that's my nightmare
yeah i get so seasick they're docked
though
but no just the i don't think they do
that in doc
they're too heavy yeah
they don't they don't really even do
that unless it's really bad sees i don't
think
you can feel a lot oh every time i've
been on a cruise i'm
green have you been on a chris yeah i've
been on
i've been on cruises neil have you been
on here cruises are like uh
chris brown of the sea where i'm like
how are you still doing this
how are people still doing yeah how are
people still interested in this
i went on a cruise as a kid that's more
fun
cruise as a kid was fun but i went on
once as
an adult first of all
cruises are floating vegas everybody in
vegas
put on the water cruise um
not great i didn't have a lot of fun
and i i just felt this overwhelming
sense of anxiety of how wasteful they
are
oh that i that i would find unbearable
so
it was just when you look at the smoke
coming out of the chimney or the back
where they're just [ __ ] dumping
sewage and most cruises fly
on either the plane panamanian flag or
whatever
something in the industry with no
with no regulations with no regulations
so they're they're
under panamanian law for example and
um so those people make about
fifty dollars a month yeah because they
don't have to play like it'll be a
carnival cruise line yeah but it's not
it's not it's like
you know they do it under wherever they
can pay the lease all the people are
from different countries
so um they get it's all just on tips
essentially and i think they make good
money for
wherever they're coming from why would
they do it but there was a woman in the
documentary who's like
mother of two at sea
yeah no it's a lot of like and i the
the people i was with figured out that
they could take off the
gratuity at the end of the trip by the
people you were with you mean your
family your
close friends no no no you went on a
cruise with not your family
this is the biggest crime of the whole
thing with friends
it was not i just like learned my lesson
it was just not
i didn't like i've never heard a good
cruise story ever it's all
either there's no either you hear
nothing or you hear
diarrhea pulls or death
yeah so this is a nothing story it's not
it wasn't that bad it was fine
yeah but i it just it was floating vegas
can't escape well it also it does bring
to mind when will
buffets be back i need a buffet here's
the thing i love buffets you know i love
buffets you send me photos of buffets
every time you're in asia
i think will they come back will they
come back
i think they have to i think this
country needs that can you talk to one
of
the golden corral um
yeah i they i think they have i think
there's gonna
they'll be a thing where you can do
vegas special waiver
of course they will they will have it at
like they'll have it at [ __ ]
they hold on there's an article from
june 29th of last year oh how little we
knew
uh when will the phase reopen oh they're
so
80s and dates with or without a vaccine
oh they updated in march so that's good
um it's regularly updated forever
probably gonna be somebody giving you
the buffet
you know well here's the thing that it
goes
on un un remarked upon
is almost no cases of coveter from
touching
it's all aerosol it's like 90 something
percent aerosol it's not
like wash your hands you need to [ __ ]
wash your hands stop doing that [ __ ]
yeah that just prevents
my mind
oh strap oh yeah i got i actually did
get strapped during covet
so you're welcome so susceptible i was
licking a buffet and i'll never forgive
myself for it
okay wait so the last cruise i saw
a documentary i don't remember the name
of it it's all in spanish my bad
but it basically talks about how
the political climate of mexico got to
today so it goes back into like it
starts back in the 60s
and it just talks of politics and i
didn't realize
mexico was a one-party system until
the 80s 90s what was the party it's
called like pri
or rpi were they what was what were they
about
they were well so i wasn't gonna say
it's interesting enough i'm only halfway
through it
but then i'm also watching narcos mexico
season two and i'm like
and then i watched another thing and
you're dreaming about it now and you
don't remember what you saw and what you
i'm
getting i'm starting to see a picture
but basically
um any opposition is killed they just
kind of you think that's that's that's
jungle it's the world's really close to
jungle rules
the party what they stand for has a
little bit changed throughout the year
but they're kind of they
kind of started turning bad and there
was
basically there was this push to say
like okay we've got to change things
mexico is becoming more and more corrupt
we're losing you know power
to cartels more and more and stuff like
that and it's just you just see
how a country politically can just drop
off
the edge into a free fall where
now mexico is really [ __ ] yeah for the
people to live italy's surprisingly
[ __ ]
yeah it's like there's a lot of
countries that are [ __ ] like
i feel like 40 percent of western
countries are
kind of [ __ ] there's finding a really
healthy democracy i think is hard
when you get that when that's why people
were
that's what january 6 was so
so [ __ ] up because it's like this is
some others this is some [ __ ]
chechnya's [ __ ]
right but it's right here but it's right
here in our backyard it's right here can
you believe that
um but i will for i'm sorry that's kind
of a shitty dock watch to tell you about
it
uh i'm not gonna watch it but there's
because there's a q a on one that i
haven't watched that
oh that i watched i saw okay i saw the
episode one
it's so much it's a lot it's a lot of
it's it's a lot of like this person it's
it's servers and this the name and idea
i didn't realize about the q on one so
it's on hbo max and it's in
i think it like it's episodic yeah
i think they're on episode four it's i
didn't
realize how um
one so stupid it's so stupid
but not like how i said before i was
like that's dumb how can you believe
that
yeah the origins its origin story is so
some anonymous guy named q starts
posting on
you know 4chan or 8th channel and then
um people are following it and then he
leaves certain people's uh subs
and then you know they're all like
there's a
south african guy with half of his teeth
and he's so mad that
q left his sub and now that he left his
sub he's like well he's fake
yeah that's the fake cue right i had the
reveal
there's no amount of it's just it's
apophenia it's all that [ __ ] we talked
about a month ago it's
i'm not that drawn to watch it i started
watching the wework documentary
on hulu and
it's a lot of painting it's a lot of
like
i don't know it didn't seem exactly
journalistic
this is a guy that is a journalist
trying to go figure out like just meet
cue or get as close and so he talks to
the
the uh the two dudes who run him
right one in the philippines one in
japan yeah
it's just kind of like i don't know yet
maybe i'm just being a dick but rabbit
hole on new york times
podcast was very good okay
it's kind of about queuing on but it's
about a bunch of [ __ ] i
that i wouldn't mind listening to it as
a podcast but it it feels a little bit
hyping up just
i don't want to hype these people up i
don't want and it's like mystery like oh
and then i finally got a call back from
yeah yeah and then it shows you know
it's a jump cut to him being like
hey is my my gun and then oh
it's a teaser we're gonna interview him
next year i don't know i do yeah i got
it
i mean that's that's you gotta be
careful guys what
about these documentaries yeah anyhow
well
let's go on to the email section
guys um last week you discussed the
horrific
murders in atlanta of several asian
women
um and you discussed whether or not it
falls under the category of
hate crime or bias crime i think that
that
is part of it because we fetishize asian
women in this country
but i think the bigger issue is the
stigma of sex work so
here's my question do you think society
will start normalizing the sex industry
anytime soon
it seems like a no-brainer to me to
decriminalize that type of work would
give people
legal protections and protection from
[Music]
violent psychopaths so
how do you feel
bianca
hello my name is
just a couple orcs hanging out um
i don't know if it will spare them
violence
i don't know i just don't i think a lot
of it has to do with religious
oppression so
that's where the church going down thing
is good that's one of the areas where
it's good
but there's there's plenty of upside to
um
if weed is analogous seems positive i i
think
weed weed being like a bugaboo for a
hundred years and like it's weak
we legalize weed are you [ __ ] crazy
right it's like there's a
saying like things happen slowly and
then all at once
that's how thank you
um that's how it feels like
with weed where it's just like new york
seem like oh it's legal
like they just turned a switch and
you're like wait what no pro no
no psas no nothing against it it's legal
and it'll be fine
it'll be fine um god most of this
country is
it'll be fine i promise it will be okay
right but the reason they don't is
because
church groups and government groups uh
and parent moms for
against whatever make stigmatize it
before you could you even can have an
opinion about it
and then if you have a negative opinion
about then you're against kids
right uh so i hope sex work
is legalized it's it's
i don't think it helps being underground
no but if you go to certain countries
where it is legal
they have you know there's no need for a
pimp
there's no need for so a lot of the
other elements that go along with it
it's regulated it's yeah you get tested
regularly
tested and you know no one
stiffs you you know it's it's just like
any business transaction yeah and we're
it's all it's always going to happen so
why not
i think there'd be less room for uh
just the seems like there should be like
a yelp
for both ways god no can you imagine
i'm yeah [ __ ] was loose right no thank
you uh that's the headline [ __ ] was
loose
um it's it's a shame my biggest regret
is that can't be the title of the
episode
um i hope i hope i i
seems like there's very little downside
to legalizing it
yeah and i think it would uh help the
you know
when girls are 16 15 16 17
doing it i'm not saying you know just
wait till you're 18. but at lea
it just takes away the i don't know
maybe the
well you wouldn't if there were more
legal
19 year olds i feel like then they
wouldn't
care about 16 year olds well yeah i will
take the edge off the
like the whole underage girl it's like
okay she's still
i mean it's kind of gross to cater to
that
urge of no she's still a teen
technically like
leave the 17 year olds alone but if you
think
the magazine and website probably barely
legal
okay bear it's called barely legal
the best so stupid so stupid goodbye
you've got mail dear neil and bianca so
i'm essentially the last guy in my group
of peers who isn't a
in a long-term relationship or married
at this point we're all in our mid-30s
and i'm the only hold out for bachelor
dump i'm feeling pressure from friends
and family to settle down
the thing is it's not something i'm
really opposed to
i'm actually a very romantic person and
i like being in close affectionate
relationships
the problem is that i'm vain and
somewhat of a bastard
okay uh now i'm not an unattractive guy
i'm
not really a catch either but i'm
charming funny smart and not entirely
broke
i've been with many women who are far
more attractive than i am
and i think it kind of spoiled me the
older i've gotten i've just developed a
very strong sense of what i want from a
person
trouble is that there just seems to be a
very narrow overlap between the people
who i'm attracted to
and who are attracted to me also i like
being alone so i have no urgency to
really continuously put myself out there
to find this rare person
it could be in a relationship tomorrow
if i wanted but not with the person i
wanted if that makes sense
and i and uh i don't know i'm just
beginning to wonder if i might be too
picky or too vain mind you i'm not
insulting
i'm not insisting that i date a model i
just want someone that i'm deeply
attracted to
this is a this is a you issue kind of no
it's a i think it's a guy
it's a guy issue in that
it's a guy issue that people don't
really talk about because it's like [ __ ]
you you're a sex addict
okay um okay like europe i had this
argument with
with somebody yesterday okay if
if i told you uh
i want to set you up my friend yeah and
you said
what's he like and i said he's
33 comedian
is okay with money decent looking
and uh
has lives by himself directs commercials
you'd be like i'm listening and if i
said
same [ __ ] he's 47 you're like
yeah that's it that's it just yeah i
mean i don't i know that
it doesn't mean it's like i would think
i mean i just would
i don't know if i'd want to date a 33
year old to be perfectly honest
i hear you for other reasons because men
are just kind of funny at certain ages
and then 47 might take the first stage
it's like
you're still kind of that's what i'm
saying like then 47's
so old yeah so i don't know
i know that's what i'm saying
um so i'm not are you 47
apparently uh so i'm not asking
for for special
it's just that it's just a delicate
situation i'm not i'm not even looking
for sympathy really i'm just looking for
like
you know people wives don't like having
me around
like trouble universally
and then the person i was arguing with
was like because that's their place they
can exercise power
if like their husband's a rich guy who's
successful and popular and he brings
around it's like well yeah and then she
can be like [ __ ] that guy
um but it's married guy oh
it just it's it's a there is a moral
judgment that comes with it
yeah when not enough of it is about
like luck and and i would even go so far
as
i'll take it a step further uh
if you say you know you've never been
married you must be a little [ __ ] up
and to which i say maybe what should i
do
what should i do now i go to therapy
i i drink plant medicine i
i hasn't i haven't fallen in love with
anybody in a while
and the one people i did fall in love
with it didn't work so like what do you
want me to do
so i'm glad that i brought the podcast
to a
standstill no no i'm just listening
because
[Music]
i don't know if if you i just feel
like there's not everyone can give your
advice
give you advice because we all want to
see for some reason
everyone wants to see a successful guy
together with somebody yeah like
politics
i mean you can't you can't be really
single in politics anyway but
you want it's like that's some good seed
if that's what you mean like they you
want to see a successful guy in a
relationship
just we want you like why are you doing
something
um so i think people like the narrative
is well why
what's okay he doesn't have a girl why
yeah what's going on with neil
yeah is he messed up is he right you
know so it's never like
that's very difficult to meet people and
for anybody
it's very difficult to meet healthy
people healthy
the right people that are in the right
vibe that are that edited
like the as i say there's 50 [ __ ]
prongs that need to line up
yeah 50 prongs one's real important and
it's in my pants
um so
don't say that you're gonna you just
lost me some women
um bianca i had there were so many women
that were interested
and once you said ooh um uh
so i again and the other thing that bugs
me
is that if i was a woman i'd be a
heroine
i'd be a heroine or i'd be like a
feminist icon
or come on people tell women all the
time why didn't you have a man
of course but at least if they if
there's an article about them
in a lore it's she's feminine
fifty and fierce or whatever you know
but those women aren't also
always happy of course well but
sometimes they are that's what i do and
you are too
i that's what i'm saying like and then
even that people go what
what's wrong with you that you're happy
being you know
sarah silverman's a little older than me
single
never been married and i think uh
she's not sad about it no she's not sad
at all about it but
if they write an article about either
one of us they're going to use hers as
like
she didn't [ __ ] settle she didn't she
didn't settle for any for just
anyone she's still holding out pull
quote i just want to meet the right guy
pogba is a big one like they'll have
and she'll be in a wedding dress and
whatever in this fake article right
it's just con it's just aggravating
as a it i it's like a media thing it's
like right
it's like why is every you know x person
in ex pose do people try to do your
like well-off friends try to set you up
no why
are you open to it or have you said do
not
or any friends i just mean you know
because i think they think i'm a
[ __ ] psycho it's the truth like i
will not do that
it's like that's again all the things
and he's 33 or 4
yeah and he's never been married it's
that joke i do i'd get more credit from
women if i'd been married and murdered
my wife
than having never been married the
problem is i would such i have friends i
could set you up with but
you're a little too much of a
truth-teller you don't
use yeah i just feel like
sometimes when you tell me your stories
i'm glad i don't know these women
that's fine like you're not as healthy
as i thought you were
yep sorry about my greatest
as i thought you were to a woman i was
dating people think
it was a dis i just think it's what's
popping
imagine if she came she's like you know
what he told me she
said that to me i know but it's like
selling your friend a
car a used car she once said same girl
once said
did you meditate today because i was
being a dick she goes did you meditate
and i go yeah and she goes
did you do it right that's like are you
on your period for
mental uh mental health but did you do
it right away are people
very funny and i used to immediately say
again
i do did you write it's funny yeah was
she mad at uh you're not as healthy
she cried i believe yeah
thereby proving my point that she said
she wasn't helen
i had to finish that joke for bianca i
thought she would get it just from the
setup but i had to give her the punch
goodbye
you basement listener second time
emailer brief reaction to stop asian
hate hashtag discussion bianca said i
don't think this is bad
it doesn't hurt you to clarify your
stance on things even if it's cheesy
hashtag thing it doesn't hurt
okay personal hypothesis it does hurt
here's how it hurts it gives us the
feeling of fighting injustice and blinds
us to the fact that we're not actually
doing anything effective in the real
world to affect change
uh before the hashtag activism america
era
you could be enraged by injustice but
you had a pretty fair barometer for your
effectiveness you either did something
about it or you didn't
if you didn't do anything about it you
felt impotent or hypocritical or lazy
whatever
uh but you didn't get the dopamine hit
that being altruistic gives us
see the three mics comment about
volunteering to fight depression
hashtag activism is bad because it gives
us the illusion of having done something
and rewards us with the dopamine hit
and gives our brain permission to think
quote i've done my part
it's worse than doing nothing because
when you do nothing at least you know
you've done nothing you don't get to
feel good about it
james joyce wrote quote sentimentality
is
unearned emotion i think hashtag
activism
is unearned virtue it's a dopamine heist
that's fine he goes on but yeah he's not
wrong um
well it the only in my defense
i said so much that was against that one
line no no i don't think that you were
saying
like it's i i think that you were fine
with
making it a hashtag as a part of a
panoply of things
no i might think that when i said that
line it was after we talked about and i
said but then
when i think about it if you
are just you don't know what to do it
doesn't hurt
to maybe use your platform to spread
awareness i think he i
agree with him completely right but i
also said so much more which was
the hashtag doesn't explain anything
just posting a hashtag
and i feel like people thought it would
have the same impact as
black lives matter and it didn't it was
just stop asian hate we don't know what
you're talking about we don't know
what like it was so vague that it felt
like people thought they could be like
stop hating hate
clothes laptop i did it which is the
same thing he's saying yeah
it's not so i was saying the same thing
but then i thought about it on the other
hand
and some accounts i follow who did post
it
there were some people who did a really
good job and i don't think it hurt
i don't think that like i was thinking
of specific accounts that posted a lot
of information
along with stop asian hate that you
know if i showed it to you no one could
argue that
but i don't think i don't even think i
don't think that's bad i just don't
think it's effective like
you know i don't know i can still
because that's the
it's like people mistake good with
effective it's like
it's good it's emotionally good it's
unearned
yeah i definitely didn't say it was
effective i know it's not about me i'm
just saying
i fully agree with him and i think we
covered it so much we talked about that
for a long time
so to take the last bit and say
like i was fully agreeing with this guy
the whole time so you know i get it but
i'm gonna start a hashtag called call
the cops
i think it already exists and i'm going
to
have them have a number thank you 9-1-1
just i'm toying with some numbers one of
them is 9-1-1
um you know what's funny when you're in
another country and they
and they're 911's different they'll be
like dial eight
you're like eight doesn't even make
sense
eight that's when that joke what's the
number to 911 actually makes sense
yeah you know what you know what you
know what thank you 90s
for what's the number one little rascals
goodbye thank you
you've got a high pinky in the brain not
bad i was curious on your thoughts about
how power dynamics play out in media and
its translation to real life
a lot of tv shows about teenagers
nowadays often have adult actors with
fully formed bodies
playing a 17 16 or even 13 year olds
uh sydney sweeney in euphoria that weird
pen
15 show that's so funny pretty little
liars
uh do you think it plays a role in the
insecurities of teenage girls
or even the further sexualization of
girls also i recently wrote a paper
oh boy here we go oh no it's all this
was a classic
it was a bait and switch yep we just got
sir
we literally just got you saw it happen
live folks it doesn't happen
often
one of the quotes i found interesting in
your own paper
was quote pornographic media even
softcore media is about
sexual initiation of boys and uh we're
in ev in
invariably to work invariably the work
of grown men
revisiting and refashioning their
teenage years seeing their exploits
in a more favorable light to what extent
do you agree with this statement
do you believe that an artist who is
displaying more sexual images can assume
that their audience is fully capable
full capabilities to process the weight
of the images they say
uh that's a whole
i don't think it's the artist's fault
and if you do then you get better go
burn um taxi driver
and catch from the rye because they got
john lennon jody john lennon and ronald
reagan
shot and the authors blamed that
so but they couldn't how do we know who
can take what
right and i don't think it's up to the
artist to to
censor themselves on that regard the
thing about
teenage girls i've never been a teenage
girl
looks like a nightmare no neil they're
saying that they
like in hollywood we cast
um underage girls over age young looking
girls which is
normal well yeah cause it's they have to
be able to work
yeah they have so many they would love
listen on
disney the reason why people go to
nickelodeon disney obviously you're
going to test it
is because they have a whole system they
have school there they have
all things kids can almost barely work
in hollywood yeah well it's a limited
time and then
also you don't want a kid growing on
camera
right it's gross
it's gross if you don't believe me ask
watch a sitcom in its eighth season
i know and then remember how adorable
remember how adorable timmy was
well he's got cystic acne now and he's
hulking um so
he so be careful what you wish for bye
you've got
hello nebbin congratulations on the
100th episode quite a milestone not
really
as a listener since day one i started to
do some calculations all right let's say
every two hours of listening all is
equal to four hours in real life
uh interactive exchange with friends and
family most of us spend
still spend more time with youtube uh
per week making you guys somewhat like
family um
whatever uh we agree or not with them
your unique perspectives and humor have
shaped us
over the last two years and incredibly
influenced how we see the world
indirectly influenced uh how we see the
world interact with people at home
at the job and etc and using old man
phrases
my question one do you two devoutly
consume any podcasts or media on a
regular basis like the feelings the
feelers do
over the 100 episodes what are the
biggest sacrifices you've made in
service the show
preparation content regularity etc
100th nil spiel
century bunny tunney truly have no idea
where they go
oh whoa um
do you do anything special we both keep
a list
we have our list there so little
preparation goes
yeah it's not like well researched no we
just put a list together of what we want
to talk about
yeah and then we'll just like throughout
the week text each other interesting
[ __ ]
yeah uh it's a so yes it's a huge
sacrifice
sacrifice so to answer your question sir
came out of the mud um we got we get
this podcast out the mud
um yeah there's regularity's pain in the
ass but
yeah but neil always says it's the first
is it like
he hasn't had a job in a while
um goodbye you've got hello spirit padre
and old caribbean andre
hi pretty good i'm back with another one
back in my 20s i've seen guy who was
playwright musician
we live together in a big artist
collective as as one may do in your 20s
in the last 50 years um we didn't
actually quote hang out with each other
long but remained housemates
and after i called the sleeping together
part off he kept pushing boundaries like
showing up in my room
and crawling in my bed with me wholly
uninvited weird [ __ ]
i love how girls are like that's weird
no
nothing weird about it he just wanted to
keep having sex with you
it's just after she said hey i'm not
interested in you at all but i live
i'm i'll be in the room next door and if
you're getting
if a guy i'm not saying it's legal or he
didn't
i'm assuming he didn't force it but a
guy coming in after you've stopped
wanting to sleep with him and kind of
like
getting him back with you i don't find
abnormal at all
not behavior i do but i'm not surprised
by it at all
yes of course not um fast forward to
nowish and the guy has had a lot of
success writing on head tv shows in
hollywood
including singled out and
what else did i write chappelle show and
all that and sorry live
twice i recently googled him and
discovered he's been sacked from the
last show he was on when it came to
light that he punched an ex-girlfriend
when i pushed this to a mutual old
housemate who was still friends with
this dude
she she pushed back that there was quote
more to the story
and that the quote girl accuser was
crazy um
i said i'm sure the girl may be crazy
but there's no point offending this dude
my
friend feels bad that dude lost his
career because of this but my feeling is
that the media space is brutal with no
space for nuance these days
so you all sadly just need to keep your
noses exceedingly clean
so you don't get got i'm not saying put
them in the electric chair i'm saying
rest in power dummy
what do y'all think uh
it's hard to spin up to the
okay fine right yeah i don't
of course yeah like that's we agree that
that's bad
right but
try them and convict them and have them
do
some kind of sentence because this same
woman
would probably be in favor of
productions
uh writer writing rooms
hiring a a former felon
to rehabilitate himself so like
but like no but [ __ ] him but you're good
what's the difference if that guy killed
somebody
or that guy punched a lady and
he but you're you you're never going to
work again
i just think it's uh haphazard
and it's there's no system no there's
noises
and like well you guys need to okay
so we don't there's no there's no
reparative justice there's no
there's no justice at all if you [ __ ] up
because
because the media doesn't have nuance
well that doesn't mean it doesn't sound
like the media it sounds like
you don't have no answers um she's in
favor of not wanting him to work
uh there's a so the book some a few
people asked me about it it's called the
little book of restorative justice
it's fair did you tell me about it i
told you about it yeah and then um i
mentioned it on the podcast
uh it basically says you can't really be
in favor of canceled culture
and um uh criminal justice reform
and it's not hard to understand 70
million people that are
essentially i mean even there's times i
we say like we're hypocrites too there's
times where i'm like
[ __ ] up and then i want criminal
justice reform so
anyways the book it's really good my
friend who's a lawyer is
writing a book about kind of this and
that's one of the books he's using for
his research
so that's the name little book of
restorative
justice yeah uh we need a system it's
fun to get to be allowed to write the
rules
white people will attest but if you were
unhappy with the
way that white people what wrote a lot
of the rules
your rewrite better be fairer to
everyone
and so far it hasn't been well the
problem is you want it
it feels bad to make it fair yeah you
want it to be like
no no you just your instincts are okay
your time
no yeah no you're it's your time over
the barrel it's like it's just vengeance
it's just vengeance it's like why
countries get [ __ ] up and cultures
civilizations etc
goodbye you've got mail saw an article
the other day quote teens who set a
house on fire killing family of five
immigrants
to be tried as adults my question is
does this mean they are
legally free game for pedophiles
it's a great question what he's saying
is if you're tried as an adult
why can't you be tried why can't you be
a sexual object that's not
uh that's it this guy i believe has
written him before and i don't remember
his name but he's
had he's two for two with good jokes
that are not
useful um uh they're
good points good point what at a certain
point in comedy you get from how can i
make this good point into a joke
right but this is almost like dave's
logic a lot right
recently yeah like how old's 15 and all
that [ __ ] he did that was 15 years ago
but
um but a lot of his [ __ ] about
the white rules goodbye you've got male
banks wednesday am listener here and
haven't missed an episode my question
relates to how
it came about that neil decided to do a
podcast with bianca specifically
listen to a lot of other podcasts some
with a duo of comedians or other famous
people
but i have to say h f is the only
podcast that i listen to
every week bianca's takes are great and
i look forward to hearing
both of your opinions in a world where
there are probably too many opinions
floating around
neil was this predicated on existing
chemistry between you and bianca
that you thought would be a great
podcast or were there considerations
before her
like another comedian or possibly doing
the podcast solo
uh the reason i'm curious is it seems
the formula for most podcasts is to get
someone as famous
or more famous than you to partner with
in order to get more listeners
and by choosing someone not to in the
spotlight you've created a more
interesting podcast was that the plan
all along or did it happen to her just
turned out that way
come on bts true hollywood story
was i knew that i liked
talking to bianca and i liked
um i like talking to bianca i like being
funny around bianca and i
i knew that you were intelligent and you
were from the same world as me
and you were interesting you have an
opinion about things and that's
different than mine
and i've never stopped resenting the
fact that you're not famous
it is the biggest mistake i've ever made
i could be making 1100 bucks a week off
this thing
sorry that i left on the table uh
and also i didn't want to do it with
another comedian because i didn't want
to negotiate
i like i've had some
partnerships with comedians they can go
a little sideways sometimes
so i didn't i just thought like
even with mosha it was friction just
like pain in the ass i'm a pain in the
ass he's pain in the ass
yeah you're both who wins a painting
house from the same country
actually so it's like yeah um you said
to me
which i always loved you were thinking
about whatever and
you just said i like the way we argue
yeah instead we argue
in a way that isn't it doesn't feel like
right jerry springer or you know
sometimes
arguments are fun to watch but sometimes
they can
get old yeah it's just who wants to see
people like really not getting along
well it's not
it's it's negative yeah it's negative
energy so
and we've also gotten better at uh
not focusing on differences if we can
tell like this is intractable
and it's gonna be a problem we're gonna
walk we're just gonna i also
i have a i have a uh ayahuasca
observation
and uh ayahuasca ration
um i probably
35 percent less misogynist from doing
from being ayahuasca from doing iowa and
being ayahuasca
and doing in iowa i was gonna say i
did a joke with kat the other day that
you know how it worked she was talking
about on the bachelor
they'll have like the women don't have
jobs so they'll just have like
one time there were two female twins on
and their job was twin
so i said when next next time i'm on tv
i'm gonna have my name and then uh just
ayahuasca
underneath it that's my job um
less misogynistic yeah you are more open
to
the fact that you have a very
specific experience that is not
necessarily the norm
yeah i it's also i'm i can
more than i'll write jokes in ayahuasca
but more than that i'll
write setups like i don't like the way
like the in for that joke is [ __ ]
negative
like i have a bunch of women jokes right
yes and i just made them about
how men and women don't appreciate each
other mm-hmm
problem solved i still get in the
misogyny yeah but the setup they don't
know what it is
just no it's just it's it's a it's a
different
it's with a different setup it's a
different point
do you know what i mean yeah it's just
instead of like [ __ ] nah it's like ah
this setup is the is the aim yes it's
the it's like okay where are the
crosshairs
yes boom nice that's why we do a podcast
goodbye
i have a couple questions neil's take on
the value of college is missing two huge
points
a colleges have different admissions
requirements and associated prestige
so it's a recruiting shortcut to sift
through an enormous
amount of people okay
at 150 grand
b although the subjects neil's quote
facts
may be the same these students and to a
lesser extent the teachers are not the
same
uh i don't
uh okay that's where i get into like how
bad are the small colleges that's the
problem you can find
like where'd i wear my books ah i can't
find my chalk i'm gonna pee on the i'm
gonna use my poop
on the wall on my white board i mean
the thing is in my i have i had so many
great professors that
i mean one of my professors wrote three
books that were like
uh taught in other universities in the
you know
80s or something like that he hitchhiked
with martin luther king in hawaii
it's illegal martin luther king and the
mountaintop
so to me i think they are
older smaller colleges get he had a sign
that said
i have a dream that you'll get us to
monolani
okay
no like i think they just get older like
they were heavy hitters in the 80s
you know i don't think they're getting
uncomfortable
but i don't know but this is the thing
we argued before
i don't know what quali even
i know i know
all the people i know some very well
some
kind of well some that doesn't make me
the best
explainer of dave for instance like that
i'm clearly enti uh
qualified to speak about him but i don't
maybe the things i know about them
aren't even teachable
right they're not valuable or not i'm
not as
i am the problem is i am like a student
scholar so that's it's not a good
example but
but um so i don't think that knowing or
or being black makes you better at black
it just you know what i mean it's the
same thing where it's like i don't know
what makes a good teacher
okay yeah i also think the smaller
colleges like
there's shitty teachers at good colleges
30 of everything sucks
okay how about that it's perfect goodbye
um
just off the top hire a hundred people
30 of them suck
you've got me active tuesday listener
here i'm a
male slightly off white latinx with no
known afro roots darn it
recently i brought it to sheiki oh no
just to see what it would feel like to
wear and i gotta say it's the most
fun colorful and comfortable garment in
my otherwise conventional wardrobe
but i feel like if i dared step outside
when sl when wearing it
i'd be committing a huge cultural
appropriation party file am i correct
on a scale of one to dolezal where does
a non-black
person wearing a dashiki fall is it even
okay to wear this thing around the house
where no one else will see it or should
i give it up entirely
uh looking especially to bankerton for
advice on this one
skill one of those levels first of all i
don't think dolezal is a tent
but that's my own biases it might be a
little chat
might build chet hanks yeah but again
that's mild really yeah
i mean it's like fw de klerk would be
that
would be number 10. he brought out fw
um no i just mean it's it's it is mild
yeah it's mild now in the right
neighborhoods there's right and wrong
neighborhoods where your daisy sir
i don't think there's a right
neighborhood for a non-white person
where dashiki
i don't know i feel like if you're in a
real hippie-dippie
like i think even if you're in a
hippy-dippy neighborhood
i think if black people see you wearing
it they think you're like
well heavy-duty mostly means not black
right but i'm saying
ups forever just driving through
okay hippie dippies have packages or
entrepreneurs or
right through but i'm just saying like a
guy that you're likely to see
right right he's going to be like be
like right i don't even know if it's
i don't know what the feeling is um
that's not really a dashiki that's a
dashiki is it really
exactly okay um but i don't i think the
right color
dashiki doesn't seem uh
like a a transgression
then there's like the kente cloth nancy
pelosi chuck schumer thing which
god bless um yeah i mean i
i the daishiki i don't know just wear it
inside and don't wear it outside
wear it to bed where'd your bread that
feels disrespectful but
no no where to wear it do whatever you
want nice shirt
just don't answer the door don't go
outside with the doctor don't even keep
please look at my weight passing la tinx
and see who's there hey neil and big
shout out to some of my favorite people
in my favorite show podcast anyway
neil i'm listening to the cat as i write
this email and listen to you saying that
you don't know what to do or know
nothing about violence
or what not about asians against asians
one thing i
to quit saying [ __ ] is fun oh i like
this email okay
one thing to quit saying [ __ ] is funny
this isn't
the only time you distastefully said
that someone's death or tragedy is funny
hard to think someone with your
intelligence not aware of the history of
violence against asians in america
just concerned because the pod is a
favorite i'm a thursday listener viewer
and i hate to see in my google news feed
that you guys got cancelled to the
platform with some reckless [ __ ] you say
i think you're very funny and quick and
smart what i didn't know you can stay
the funniest for that
whatever um so you're you don't like it
when
i say that death is funny
but you do like it when i made slavery
sketches
somehow that's very funny to him how
about again
rick james a sexual
uh convict convicted sexual
predator how about virulent racism in
the ku klux klan
no problem with that my point is sir
that you don't know what you're talking
about that you think
you just go i don't like that so that's
no
i it's all fair game i say this on
behalf of all comedians all the time
everything's fair game if we can land
the joke and a lot of times
i've been able to land jokes about
slavery in my act
about but all kinds of [ __ ] right so
i don't like you saying that
you got no point well it's basically
picking and choosing yeah
no standard just like i don't like that
but you don't but
there's plenty of [ __ ] you have no
problem with that somebody else could
find offensive
but you just have your little pet issue
also the point of the podcast my friend
and
you know i'm sure you're feeler but the
point is
that we
can't always talk freely without fear of
getting canceled
right and so we want to have an open
discussion that's why people literally
call us for race and dating advice
because it's such a hot topic button i
mean such a hot topic that
we don't know people do not know which
way to move right people do not know
we've had emails that are so minor
and huge in between when it comes to
race and
men and female relationships and how to
do what is this okay is it's not okay
we that we are the place where you have
no problem with the n-word family
he had no not one issue with it still
watched it
50 times that's the thing so it's not
about
for instance or my last day of slavery
joke or
right not etc it's basically
my ray rice joke this is the place where
we come to be
um imperfect just like everyone else is
right so
and i get it hey you know what guess
what this guy is also being a hypocrite
yeah welcome to but he he emailed
it he wrote it down without seeing the
logical fallacy which
guys if you're gonna listen we need you
to
check yourself for logical fallacies you
may have already tested
positive for logical fallacies and you
don't even know it
wild to severe last time i checked
uh we didn't have to take this [ __ ] we
don't nobody guess what listeners you
don't either
no you don't it's over go back to your
life
which will now be worse because we're
not
talking in your face goodbye
good one neil